I had been thinking about something in
my own personal life about relationships
and how sometimes distance creeps in and
and it's very hard in my experience to
sort of get back across to where you
once were and so I was doing some
reading on that topic and reading about
couples who had tried to fix their
marriages or long-term relationships and
I realized that a lot of the people i
was reading about were significantly
older than I was and maybe had been
married for a long time and I just
started to think gosh i'm having trouble
it must be so much more difficult if
you're older and and these things have
become really entrenched and so I just
started wanting to imagine a couple like
that who could find it again and and I
wanted to know if I could actually
imagine it we went in for the first
meeting with Todd and he was like okay
well you could make this as a really
small movie and nobody would see it and
that would be so heartbreaking because
you put all this work into it and then
nobody would see it I really can't do it
that way so what I think we should do is
get Meryl Streep and we were all just
like well yeah I basically said I won't
make the movie for we don't get Meryl
Streep and I knew that I have the chance
of them saying goodbye because there was
another producer that wanted there are
other people that wanted it but I was so
overwhelmed from the night before
somebody my company had read it and said
we know you like good writing you should
read this it's an available script it's
been out there for a little bit and I
brought it home that night and didn't
have a lot of reading that night which
is rare and I thought oh I'll read 20
pages and go to sleep and I read 120
pages and put it down and my heart
started pounding whenever it does that
as a film producer for 20-something
years I know that I have something
amazing and then I read it again that
night and I never had done that before
the script where I was able to read it
twice in one sitting and feel the same
way and then Vanessa and her manager and
agent came in our managers and nessa
came in the next day to my office and I
thought i only can make this with meryl
streep it's Harper
material that well written that isn't
seen with an actor and there's many good
actresses of merrells age that would be
great in it but I knew at least with
marrow audiences you love Meryl right so
you you want to come and see that and I
I thought I can't make the movie and
have nobody go see it and I and I
literally called up Merrill's agent who
I knew well and said I have to come and
see you and walked the script into his
office and he's like I've known you 20
years why are you in my office of the
script and I said because I have
Merrill's next movie and you're gonna
want her to do and she's going to want
to do it and I for some reason I was so
confident in the material and in Vanessa
quite frankly that I knew she would say
yes and this was on a Thursday and on a
Monday Kevin humane Merrill's agent who
made really made this happen called me
and said you were right it's one of the
best scripts I've ever read and Meryl's
going to want to do it sit tight and we
SAT tight for a year Merrill was doing
another movie called it's complicated
and she was a little tired after that
shoot and kevin i would call kevin every
couple weeks and then i would call
vanessa and guymon every couple weeks
and say sit tight sit tight and sure
enough about a year later Kevin said I'm
With Marilyn New York she read your
script she's firmly committing let's go
make the movie the whole feeling was
never to feel anything but the
characters and the emotion don't I mean
it's a very it's seemingly it looks so
easily directed it's actually very hard
when you have dialogue movies and
emotion movies to to not get in the way
and do jazzy camera things and i think
david frankel did an unbelievably good
job of just letting it flow and letting
the camera sit there and when you need
to push in push in and when you don't
just let it sit there and don't be
afraid of master shots and don't be
afraid to go in really close to me there
were some close-up shots and meryl
actually came to us you were there and
she looked at us and she could
get close and David said how close and
she goes close and David said like that
and she pushed us and she goes like that
because I'm real I want to be real I
want people I want to be relatable to
everybody because I am and and and we
said Tommy Tommy's like get real go
close